[Music]
now we're gonna go out to denver
colorado with miguel and go keep it real
with him
hey good afternoon how can we help how
you doing anthony
doing all right man how are you doing
well thank you um so just kind of a
little bit of a dilemma right now so i
am currently 25 years old
um i am making about 60 000 a year right
now hold on
we got a dilemma you 25 making 60k
let me hear this dilemma all right let's
see um
so i'm 28 000 in student loans um
the other thing is so i just recently
got engaged um and this is where this
all comes in
i own a 2020 tacoma which i got for 47
and right now i owe
33. obviously my fiance and i we want to
build our own life we want to get our
own place and this and that
um my dilemma right now is in if i
should sell the tacoma
and use that 700 a month i'm paying to
pay out my student loans save up for a
bigger down payment
uh right now i am saving about a
thousand a month uh
but yeah that's kind of where i'm at
right now how much money do you have in
your savings account right now
about 13 thousand thirteen
thousand dollars okay if you sell this
this car
oh it's actually suv right um
it's a truck truck okay yeah um
what can you sell it for so you owe 33
on it what can you get for it
um so the valley on kelly blue book for
the base model
it is 41 000 i do have the premiere
package on it
um so i've been looking at i've been
here and i can sell it for up to 43 45
000.
so you can get forty three thousand
dollars right now for the cost yeah
yeah how much do you love your wife i
mean your future wife
uh love it to death that's why i'm
thinking of selling my babies
with her that's what i'm talking about
brother i'm selling that thing today i'm
getting off the phone
and i'm selling it and what i would do
is i'll go ahead and sell it for
private and see if i can get 45
that'll put you 12k and then what i
would do is honestly
i would take 10k of that go buy a car
add the other 2k uh with the 13
000 you have saved up okay and then i
would use that 15
000 to cash flow your wedding
and and and again i'm not dave and this
is anthony's opinion
i think right now because how much debt
does she have
uh she has about i think it's just her
car which shields about ten thousand on
okay cool so and what
you make 60k how much does she make so
she just graduated
um so she's still working at her
internship she's only making about 14 an
hour right now
okay so she's about now once she um gets
into her career field
what can she make on average let's say
low low end
well i want to say 20 an hour 20 an hour
okay cool so that
that's pretty decent all right cool so
this is what i want to suggest to you
man
okay uh all seriousness um
one of the things that that i tell
people your car value should never be
more than half of
your salary you're already there so i'm
with you
i'm selling this car uh today and you
know what
if you want to get out of it quickly so
that way you're not
putting more miles on it i will go ahead
and sell it for
you know forty three thousand dollars uh
so that way
it gives someone else the benefit and a
little bit of encouragement to get into
it because they're saving two thousand
dollars
on the car so you'll get ten thousand
dollars and you can go in ahead
and go buy you a cash car um you could
buy a good cash car in between five and
ten thousand dollars that's reliable to
get you back and forth to work and even
a decent car i mean that's a good honda
it's a good toyota that's a good nissan
altima i mean you can get you can get a
good quality car now it may not be a
truck
um but it's a good reliable car then the
thirteen thousand dollars i want you to
sit down with your fiance
and i really want you all to have a
conversation okay and this is something
that
i'm not a relationship expert right uh
but i am single
and i look forward to having this
conversation with my fiance whenever
um god allows me and blesses me to find
the love of my life i want to ask like
what what are our goals
like where do we see ourselves in the
next 10 15 years
as a couple okay what do we want do we
want to be homeowners
uh do we want to be traveling around the
world do we want kids
and then we can when we can really
identify that vision then let's work
backwards
and then that should be able to answer
this one question how much money do we
really want to
put into a wedding do we really want to
drop 15 000
20 000 on a wedding right now you know
we rather just put maybe five grand into
a good wedding
and then take this other money and put
it towards our debt so we can move
towards our goals
now i'm not knocking people who want to
spend a lot of money on
their wedding i do not but i do want to
make sure that i give you the
information
miguel and just help set you up to make
the right decision
moving forward makes sense yes yeah so
i would definitely say your car i would
um definitely uh going ahead and have
the conversation with your wife and
start seeing okay what's our budget
for the wedding okay and then from there
you two move forward but i'm super
excited do y'all have a date for y'all
gonna get get married
so yeah so i mean that's kind of where
we're at um plan was to do it september
of uh next year um
in the back of our head we were also
like okay well we can spend on the
wedding we can also spend
on a down payment for a home and later
on if we're
well off financially then we can have
the wedding that we've always wanted
um why are you waiting so long what was
that
why are you waiting so long that's a
that's another year some change
that's a long engagement brother wedding
weddings are so expensive that we just
wanted to save up and not going dead
with the wedding as well
you know wedding doesn't have to be
expensive
you you are correct you make it
expensive so i gotta convince her to do
the same way man you know as a matter of
fact i bet you this
i tell you this much okay hang up the
phone call
your girlfriend okay tell her to call
back into the show tell her to tell
kelly
that anthony told me to call the ramsey
show because he want to talk to me
about wedding and how much we should pay
for it because here's the thing america
you know we do not have to spend a lot
of money
on getting married no we don't have to
do it
who cares if america says we should
spend 20 grand 15 grand
america ain't paying for the bill okay
so here's the thing you set the budget
and you get creative with that budget
that's the bottom line